From time to time, individuals ask questions...
...that take you away from the main discussion or get you off-topic.
And here's what you can say to manage this:...
That's a great question,...
...but I want to make sure that we have time to get through our full agenda.
So, let's come back to it at the end today.
Thanks for asking that question.
I'll make sure that we save time at the end of our meeting today...
...to answer any questions that are outside of the agenda.
Similarly, you want to ensure that no one dominates the conversation...
...or takes the conversation off-track.
If you notice that someone starts to do that,...
...you can jump in and say something like:...
"That's a really great idea,"...
...or "That's a great suggestion."
"Hold on to that thought...
...because I'd like to come back to it at the end of the discussion today,"...
...or "I appreciate your comment, Sue."
"That's a really good point."
"Let's see what others have to say on that."
And lastly, if you know there's just a little bit of time left...
...and you still have topics that you need to discuss on your agenda,...
...you can say something like:...
We are almost at the end of the meeting.
So, let's try to get through the last three items.
This will help everyone return their focus to the meeting agenda.